is there a connection between anime
sensuality and depression and when I say
children I mean ages 12 to probably 18.
tell me they're starting to hear voices
in their head find out on this episode
of LED live
[Music]
welcome to another episode of LED live
today's topic is on anime and uh this is
going to be a topic that you're gonna
start to see more and more I mean we
have floated through Walmart animes on
all the t-shirts it's on Netflix this
stuff is starting to get everywhere so
today we're going to discuss a little
bit of the details of it but I have my
good friend Eric good to see you again
welcome to the show Good to be here he's
basically part of our team because he's
been on so many of our shows but we just
love having you Eric you are a wealth of
wisdom and it's been awesome learning
God God is very merciful what God has
shown him but I actually Eric is one of
the first few people I remember
mentioning anime to us years ago we
started talking about this and we did a
documentary on martial arts Eric had
spent 25 years in the martial arts world
and that's how I first got connected to
him but anime is obviously coming from
the East and so
um you know you were kind of probably
exposed to that even way back when just
getting involved in martial arts right
well for me I never read it or watched
it you know anime or Manga but a lot of
my students and I'm not talking about
young students a lot of the students
that were in their 20s and 30s they
would come in they were constantly
talking about these shows or these books
and I was like well they're cartoon
books I mean you guys are adults what
are you doing and I didn't get it and
then I can remember back it was earlier
this year you came up on a trip uh and
we got to share a series at at a high
school it's an academy in North Carolina
and tell us a little bit about that that
was shocking so I'll give you a little
backstory on this because we were
invited to actually speak specifically
on the topic of anime and what's strange
about that is that is not the first time
that's happened in fact we made a
documentary that that is all about anime
we'll put the link in the description
below
um but we had been talking about this
for years and it was like nobody's
watching anime it's this little small
subgroup over here right especially in
their Christian school but then Netflix
like just blew this whole topic out of
the water and the easy access to just
binge watching videos Netflix really
brought a lot of these obscure
um cartoons from from Japan over to the
United States and now this business is
just booming and what's crazy about out
uh anime is they discuss very very dark
deeply
um controversial things there's brother
sister relationships incest uh murders
all kinds of things that you normally
wouldn't see in a cartoon and even more
so probably wouldn't even see in in a
real life movie it's not as as common um
but these things are put in in the
cartoons all the time there's a warning
with it yeah yeah we when we put the
video out this is how strongly we feel
about the actual topic is when have you
ever seen a Ministry video that has a
warning label on it like is this one you
really need to prayerfully consider
um you know if you're really never going
to get exposed to this this is almost
one that we would tell you you know yeah
skip over watching this but you know if
your child is interested in this they
have friends about it it might be
something that you as a family can sit
down and prayerfully watch and consider
it because it is very very dark it was
shocking to me I mean you know I'm an
adult and I watched it and I was like oh
I had to turn my head away a couple of
times yeah but we feel passionate about
it and we created that documentary a
four-part series documentary because we
really feel like this is not going away
it's getting more and more and more and
that's right and if you just like Google
the graph of how much anime is actually
affecting the population and are not
affecting how much is is entering into
the population where they want to go in
10 years is like four times what it is
now so this is going to become a problem
if it not is not already and yes walking
through Walmart you see it on all the
t-shirts so this is this is a topic I
think that it's time that we understand
and and and be clear what what where we
should draw the line yeah so Eric and I
went up there and and spoke to the kids
about this but
um just to kind of give you an idea of
of like why I think this is an important
topic just this last year we got invited
to about six different locations that we
literally were asked to come talk on
this topic and I've had multiple
children when I say children I mean ages
12 to probably 18 tell me they're
starting to hear voices in their head
yeah now this is not something that that
you hear commonly because somebody
watched a movie yeah you know I mean
it's like it's like there's a lot of
people watching a lot of dark horror
movies and this and that and I I rarely
if ever have heard somebody mention that
and I've heard it time and time and time
again so for whatever reason anime I
think opens up a door and and I think
there's something really demonic about
it that's interesting you brought that
up because I mean we haven't scripted
this but you bringing up voices we're
actually going to get into that you know
in this uh in this program awesome so
let's get into this so tell me tell me a
little bit about like your you know when
did you first start kind of getting
exposed to this or looking into it well
when I when I was teaching the martial
arts I had students that were in it and
I just dismissed it I thought it's silly
I mean you're adults what are you doing
watching cartoons I don't I don't
understand that
um
but then when when we begin having
people contact us at our ministry and
they were asking questions specifically
about depression about Suicidal Thoughts
a lot of people have contacted us about
sexual sin about I'm in bondage to
pornography or I'm in bondage to
activities that are worse than just
looking at a Playboy magazine and it was
like you have to start looking for
common denominators and when you start
seeing there's a connection over all
these people there's something they have
in common
um so it started making me really ask
questions and really pray about what
what's behind this what's working behind
the scenes that we don't see now just to
be fair all anime is is Japanese
animation that anime is just kind of
like the the the word for anime comes
from Japan right yes so it's the style
of video that's made and I don't think
it's quite fair to say all of them are
demonic I don't think that's fair right
I think there's there's definitely some
adult orientated themes in them but it's
like saying cartoons are evil right well
there's some good cartoons out there
right so I think what ropes people in is
they may start with a really intriguing
story but if you talk to any one of
those kids and you you check in two or
three years down the road they're why
watching things that are absolutely
awful and you don't normally see those
kind of things in a cartoon you don't
see the cartoon characters have sex you
know Satan knows what he's doing he
starts you with a an easy drug it's just
it's just marijuana no big deal right
and pretty soon you're doing meth or
you're doing crack or you're doing speed
or but you have to keep getting
something darker because of what happens
inside the mind and another thing that
I've learned over this topic is you know
like movies you watch a movie maybe
there's a sequel maybe there's a Trilogy
or something right so that's maybe three
hours could be potentially six hours of
time that you've invested into those
characters certain animes have hundreds
of episodes
and so it's not I mean like Dragon Ball
Z 600 and something episodes this is not
a small you are investing Decades of
time into these things and and in Japan
they're so serious about their anime
that the writers if they actually write
the end of the story and somebody dies
that the that the audience didn't want
they will actually send death threats to
the writers and threaten their lives
simply because they didn't write the end
of the story like everyone thought it
should be ended so this is a serious
topic it is very serious
let uh let me open with a Bible verse
this is from Deuteronomy chapter 18
verse 9 through 12.
the Lord tells us
when thou art come into the land which
the Lord thy God giveth thee and he's
speaking to each of us Thou shalt not
learn to do after the Abominations of
those Nations so when Israel was moving
into Canaan you had all these nations
that worshiped false gods and pagan gods
and God was like I don't want you
adopting their ways of worship their
ways of living
he says and then he gets specific he
says there shall not be found among you
anyone that maketh his son or daughter
to pass through the fire
or that useth divination and that means
to Divine the future uh whether it be
through cards or palm reading whatever
and then he says or an observer of times
that means an astrologer or an enchanter
that means to hiss or whisper a spell
or a witch or a charmer and that's
interesting because that means a
hypnotist literally or a consultor with
familiar spirits or a wizard or a
necromancer which is one who talks to
the dead so God said don't learn these
things don't have anything to do with
these things
and then it gets very specific he says
for all that do these things are an
Abomination unto the Lord and because of
these Abominations the Lord thy God does
drive them out from before thee so when
I'm reading that I mean I'm
understanding all this is bad stuff God
doesn't want me to do it but then I read
that last statement
all that do these are an Abomination
unto the Lord God and I was like
why I mean this person is involved with
watching horse racing and God goes not
only is the horse racing an Abomination
and that's just an example
but the person that's doing it has now
become an Abomination to me and that
that strong language especially when you
you know the mercy of God God is very
merciful yes like like in fact you you
see him over and over and over again
laboring for hundreds of years with
people yeah and and you know like like
when he told the Israelites don't don't
destroy these people go around I'm not
done working with them yet
this is something that God is like look
I'll drive you out you you Tinker with
any one of these things because they're
all counterfeits of God right telling
the future only God can tell the future
right speaking to the dead no no you
should be speaking to the Living God
right not why would you go to the the
dead so all those little items that it's
giving in there is really just a
counterfeit for our relationship that we
need with God so these are how the
Nations served right and and what's
interesting is about Japan one percent
of Japan is Christian yeah one percent I
know it's actually less than that right
and so they're putting their ideas into
their stories how are you not soaking
that up that's exactly right it's funny
because
God says that the people that do this
are an Abomination because they're
allowing something to come into them by
watching it by reading it
so that would be like you know and
Scotty you're married I'm married that
would be like me going home and finding
out that my my wife was having you know
five different men came and visited her
one on each day of the week
I mean that's filthy how would I feel
about being intimate or kissing my wife
knowing five other men have been kissing
her and who knows what they're doing
for God he's like when you're allowing
these spirits to come into you
you're my wife you're my bride that's
why it's an Abomination that's why it
makes Abomination is something that's
filthy it makes God want to vomit so
it's not that he's like I hate you I
want to kill you he's like
why would you let yourself be treated
this way
in Revelation 18 it talks about this in
our day and it says there followed
another Angel saying Babylon is Fallen
is fallen and that doesn't mean just
Rome it means the world God has a city
called New Jerusalem well everything
else is Babylon there's two kingdoms
Babylon has fallen because she has
become the habitation of devils and the
stronghold of every foul spirit and cage
of every unclean and hateful bird and
and Babylon
um you know if if I remember reading
correctly
um when those kings would overtake a
nation instead of just saying you can't
worship your God you need to worship
ours they would just soak them up and
incorporate all that that's right so all
those different worship ceremonies mixed
together caused confusion yes and and so
the World Systems is a system of
religion but it's a confused system
that's right and when you try to mix the
world with God in his way of doing
things that causes even more confusion
this one really hit me in Romans chapter
1 verse 28-32 God actually talks to us
and he says he lists this whole list of
Abominations this whole list of terrible
sins and he says
speaking to us as as Christians who
knowing the Judgment of God that they
which commit such things as these that
were just described are worthy of death
not only do they do the same things but
they have pleasure in them that do them
that means they enjoy watching and I
thought well I would never murder
somebody but I've sat in front of a TV
screen or a movie theater screen and
watched thousands of murders
yeah you remember Rambo yeah and you
there used to be videos that would count
how many bodies they would kill I know
and you'd be like yeah he's in there
with this big gun and he's mowing
everybody down and you just see human
life like dying I know and it's like
yeah you're right you're taking pleasure
in this awful thing like like if you
really sit down and think spiritually
what's happening those people if that
was a real situation that may be the
last opportunity they had their their
fate is sealed at that moment you know
so I mean for for us as a Christian for
me to go that's just TV and God is going
you're telling me that you won't do it
but you'll pay money to watch somebody
else do it that's a pervert Yeah I mean
that that's true that's really twisted
to think that way and when when I saw
that I was like man what have I been
watching you know all these years ago
yeah now this this is sort of tying it
all together
all art forms are manifestations of
spiritual influence and Powers all art
forms I mean if you go somewhere and
there's a museum and you're looking at
art and you go
I don't even know why that's here I mean
that's not inspired or you hear a song
and you're like that's I mean it's got
nothing to it it's just blah
art was meant to be inspired but we have
to ask inspired by who
so drama acting music scripture or
sculpture and even authorship are art
forms that draw their power to Captivate
their audiences from inspiration
so what I started asking was if that's
true
where do our artists get their
inspiration from today
you know it's not just art as well
um I had an architectural friend that uh
he when he went to school he he wanted
to become an architect and I remember
him having conversations with me that
that as they would design these
buildings they would actually study
ancient religions Babylonian religions
and things wow and even the position of
the building to the way that the sun
moves and everything was a thought in
the process of building a building so
you know it's not done by accident it's
not in my accident and I think that that
this is an aspect that people a lot of
people don't think of but that yes
you're right there's a lot of spiritual
things that go into art yeah this is an
article that was done in 2020 in
sciencealert.com
they said some professional authors can
become so immersed in their own writing
they can actually hear their characters
voices in their head new research shows
famous novelists like Alice Walker David
Nichols and Enid Blyton have known to
have admitted to watching listening and
chatting with their imaginary Creations
can you imagine that you're writing a
story and you're hearing the voices in
your head Stephanie Myers when she wrote
the Twilight series that she described
it like that really she she had a dream
and a vision of basically one of the
scenes and then the characters were
there and then they would audibly tell
her like you know talk with them like
that and she said you would just quickly
write you know like whatever she was
having this conversation in her head
that's scary that's very scary
and they go on and say now a
comprehensive survey examining this
phenomenon suggests that many other
writers can do the same thing
the guardian which is a very very
popular news source
and they said in partnership with the
guardian researchers at Durham
University studied 181 professional
writers who attended the Edinboro
International Book Festival in either
2014 or 2018. the findings revealed that
63 percent of authors could hear their
characters speak while they were writing
and 15 percent of the authors could
actually enter into the dialogue
themselves I hear them in my mind one
respondent wrote
you know I I when I hear things like
this it just makes sense why how are you
learning about the kingdom of God the
the Bible is a collection of a bunch of
Stories of the way that God worked with
those people well the devil is the best
Bible student there is out there right
he he studies that thing probably way
more than than all of us and now
spiritual things are spiritually
discerned but he's mimicking what God's
doing and as you know the Holy Spirit
speaks to you he's like oh yeah watch
this I can speak to my people too and
give them Inspirations and things like
that it's just I see the counterfeit
over and over and over again of the
devil just taking what God does with his
with with us with his creation he's
interacting with us and he just perverts
it so you know what's interesting in
John 6 63 Jesus said the words that I
speak unto you they are spirit and they
are life so when we're reading the Bible
yes it's a story but it's not just the
story there is a spirit God's spirit
that is in every word right so when
you're reading it especially out loud
his spirit is coming into you so if I'm
reading something the devil inspired
what spirit is coming into me it's true
here's a very secular uh example Carl
Young he was a Swiss psychiatrist he
wrote that he had experienced many
different visions and voices he thought
some of these were part of his
subconscious but he believed that others
were Supernatural so anybody that's went
into Psychiatry they've had to read some
of Young's writings yeah so then you
find out that young is actually hearing
voices while he's writing out all this
stuff that people hold up and look up to
and young is a is known as like a a
modern Gnostic right yeah he's he a lot
of his work isn't gnosticism basically
yes but uh yeah young and Freud are the
two those are the two leaders in that
field
in Time Magazine they went on and said
one of the voices he heard he called
this voice Philemon appeared to him when
he needed advice or guidance Dr Young
said at times this voice Philemon seemed
almost physically real I walked up and
down the garden with him and he was to
me what the Hindus call a guru now this
image is very interesting with I mean
this is the cover of Time Magazine with
the snakes around a tree and they're two
snakes yeah it's the oral boras oh yes
because it's the same snake but it's
just the bot the base is underwater so
yeah you can't quite see it oh yeah yeah
yeah isn't that scary
so what I started realizing is instead
of me thinking okay well there's some
things that are just benign
like Jesus said if you're not for me
you're against me there's there's very
little in this world that is just
neutral it's being developed it's being
used by either one of two great Powers
either it's being used by the Lord Jesus
or it's being used by the enemy so I
started really being
careful with what I put in front of my
eyes what I put them in front of my ears
I think really because of the spirit
that you have is either the Holy Spirit
or we're a vessel so if you're if you're
pushing the Holy Spirit out you don't
want God in your life I mean he's a
gentleman he's not going to force
himself upon you and so
um if you're emptying yourself of
anything God dwelling inside of you well
we know the devil can dwell inside you
there's plenty of examples of demonic
spirits and things like that that can
come inside of you but they're not
asking for permission they're just
they're just they're they're getting you
crack the door open and they rush in you
give them a reason to be able to come
into your life whether it's something
you have in your life whether you watch
something that that can actually open a
door and that's why I think people are
starting to hear voices in their head
like these young kids that are talking
about anime and it's like
you're hearing these voices what did you
do that opened that door I know I know
and a lot of people open that door and
they don't know how to get rid of the
voices they don't know how to close the
door again because once the door is
opened Satan does not leave an evil
spirit will not leave unless he's forced
out by the Lord Jesus Christ through the
blood of Jesus that is the way you can
amen send that spirit's existence in
your life amen so this is actually the
whisper of serpents we're hearing a
voice but it's not our voice and it's
not God's voice it's another
now this was interesting this is goes
along with what you were talking about
in 2019 the Japan anime industry was
valued at 24 billion US dollars with
more than 48 percent of its Revenue
coming from overseas sales the have 24
billion in Japan but 48 percent comes
from around the world much of it from
America and Europe
the world market value is projected to
reach
26.9 billion by the end of 2022. that's
that's unbelievable for something that
15 years ago was still you know the
percentage of people that were in you
know watching these things and that
tells me like you were talking about
with Netflix somebody is influencing the
people that are allowing this stuff and
pushing this stuff whether they realize
it or not
according to recent statistics there are
between 90 and 100 million anime viewers
worldwide a hundred million
with Netflix reporting that more than
half of their Global viewers now stream
anime online I remember seeing the
fourth most watched anime in our country
when we were doing
um the the Xbox yeah it wasn't the
fourth most so I should repeat that it
wasn't the fourth most watched anime it
was the fourth most watched anything
during that period on Netflix was an
anime called
um seven deadly sins and it was straight
I mean just taking the ideas of God the
Bible flipping everything upside down
the Ten Commandments or actually the
villains in the story and the whole
purpose of the anime is to destroy the
Ten Commandments and that was the fourth
most watched thing not just Anime movies
TV anything like that fourth and it was
like
doesn't our country know what the Ten
Commandments are I mean I don't I don't
know if you've have you ever met anybody
that doesn't know what the Ten
Commandments I have never come up to
somebody and someone tell me what is The
Ten Commandments I don't know what that
is I've never heard of that every single
person in this country I think has
either heard of God or you know at least
somewhat of the Bible and so the fact
that that could be a a highly watched
show and nobody in our country bats and
I
we're supposed to be a Christian Nation
a lot of times people are like what
you've said before they think that
there's no harm it's just make believe
I'm just watching it it can't hurt me
but they don't realize a door can be
open and the insidiousness of it being
in a cartoon form yes accentuates the
idea that well this is a cartoon this
isn't even real and and psychologically
I think it just puts out there that yeah
because it's it's just fake you know
yeah there's no impact and how many
parents buy the videos or buy the books
for young children without ever reading
them and checking them for themselves
right right because it's a cartoon right
I'm just going to show a couple of
examples back when I was you know still
in the martial arts that were were
really big um Evangelion was really big
there was also one called Spirited Away
which was it was very very popular
um that one got a lot of people's
attention and it also was one of the
ones that was uh
highlighted in the U.S you know very
strongly
here's a couple that Disney promoted one
was called Howl's Moving Castle the
other one was called wolf children which
for me I think is is kind of funny
because you've got this woman and she's
got two children that have tails like
wolves so what has to happen for a woman
to have children that are half wolf and
half
human
not possible unless it's like demonic
she would have had to have committed
bestiality oh I mean yes it couldn't
happen but I'm saying that's implied
right right right right and that's and
that's what that that's where I think
people don't understand these cartoons
are discussing if you had a real life
movie discussing a woman having
bestiality there's no way there's no way
it would be released anywhere wait and
all of a sudden because it's a cartoon
oh it's just a story I know I know
if you look at the right hand side of
the screen this one really was was
interesting it's called Princess
Mononoke
um this is the American version that
Disney promoted look at the cover and
pay close attention to it and then I'm
going to show you its original cover in
Japan I want you to notice the top of
that Mononoke image there to what does
it say one of Roger Ebert's top 10. do
you know who Cisco is
and uh Roger R those are those are huge
movie reviews and whatever they put a
stamp of approval on I mean they're like
the top of the of the food chain when it
comes to the reviewers so them telling
you that this is one of their top 10
tells you that this is this is not just
a little obscure title right this is in
the world in a mighty way right
and this this was so this was scary this
is what they did in America this is the
cover for the DVD they didn't change the
DVD
let me show you what the cover looks
like in Japan oh interesting look at the
one on on the left hand side of the
screen that's actually the one in Japan
and then this is the Japanese version of
it that's written in English so is that
blood on her face that is blood on her
face with a dagger in her left hand it's
interesting the dagger's in her left
hand and you know the left hand way
always involves Satanism oh interesting
yeah if you if you do research on that
the left hand way it always involves
Satanism interesting so she's holding
the dagger in her left hand she's got
blood on her face like she's been eating
something there's there's a wolf behind
her but what is she holding in her right
hand a head a mask of a mask it's funny
because how many movies come out that
talk about masks because when you put a
mask on you can pretend to be something
right that's right I remember there was
one that uh Tom Cruise had done years
ago with Nicole Kidman and everybody
goes to this party and you're wearing a
mask and anything goes nobody asks any
questions right right but this is what
it looked like in Japan and they said
look we really can do something with
this in America but we're going to have
to change the cover yeah so they changed
the cover and they make it look innocent
you've got a you know like a samurai
warrior with a sword
[Music]
so that's what the devil does he re puts
a new package on something and you're
still swallowing the same poison
so what what I had to ask was
the image and character of who if by
beholding we're changed what am I being
changed into if I watch this what is
this changing me into what is watching
these cartoons right how is it affecting
me an animal you know it's like it's
like Man was created to be the the the
dominating you know creation amen and to
be the top and it's like the devil takes
that in his life's trying to work you
backwards like you don't want to be the
top you want to be more like the animal
kingdom you know that's right now some
of these are going to be just slides
that that will a picture's worth a
thousand words so that means I cannot
talk as much but I want you to see what
what we're looking at yeah in Isaiah
chapter 3 verse 9 God actually tells us
the show of their countenance doth
witness against them now if you just
Google
anime
Google this most popular anime and look
at the images you will see image after
image after image of just anger Fury
rage evil like they don't look like they
would be someone that you want to hug
from no you know no and and that yeah
that right there says a lot
this is uh out of the Smithsonian
Magazine and this is this is covering
sort of what you were talking about the
Japanese are mostly Buddhist or Shinto
and in a nation of 127 million only
about one percent identify themselves as
Christian the country Harbors a large
floating population of what's called
folk religionist Enchanted by the
mysterious The uncann Uncanny and the
counter-intuitive they find spiritual
fulfillment in being eclectic
that means that you can have a little
bit of of everything you can incorporate
them all into one
they find spiritual fulfillment in being
eclectic says Richard Fox young a
professor of religious history at
Princeton Theological Seminary that is
he says you can have it all a feeling of
closeness to Jesus and Buddha and many
many many other Divine figures without
any of the obligations that come from
being a more singular religious
orientation once again Babylon the
mixture and confusion of all these
religions together you cannot take all
these different you know belief systems
and religions and mix them together and
have something come out that's Holier
that's right so that's that's the
background of where this thing called
anime comes from doesn't mean I'm
against Japanese people obviously I love
Japanese people and there are some
strong Christians in the Japanese just
like there's some strong Christians in
America right but we need to identify
what's causing this what's working
behind this right but if there's a
majority of people people that are
serving you know Buddhism and Shintoism
and all these other different religious
systems you know you you wonder like as
God spoke about those Nations way back
when right don't do as these heathens do
and you know you hear the way that God
spoke about them it's interesting that
people get offended so easily and like
oh you know how can you how can you talk
about this well you know I I wonder what
God would say in this current day and
age if he was here and use that language
and wrote that down would people still
have a problem even though it was God
that said that you know yeah
unfortunately I think they would yeah of
course because his his word doesn't need
to be updated right I mean he gave it to
us and the principles of his word are
the same as what they were six thousand
years ago right right amen
this this is the question that comes a
lot yeah but I watch Christian anime or
I read Christian manga and I just out of
curiosity I typed in Christian anime and
it brought up this manga book
um it's called manga Messiah and I
didn't I didn't include a lot but when
you read the title on the cover and the
fine print and you open up the story and
you start realizing what's being taught
in it is it really christ-like so the
top of this um manga right here it says
has he come to save the world or destroy
it that sounds like some of the
Hollywood Marvel movies well yeah I mean
I wonder is that like supernostic if you
actually flip through this and scene no
I've only seen what they had online yeah
yeah I would be curious to see how they
actually and answer that you know do you
know what's scary for me too is is how
do they portray Our Savior yeah does
Jesus want to be made to look like a
bobbling little or does he want to be
made to look like
you can't take the son of almighty God
who spoke the universe into existence
and put him in a shape that is like
like anime that's it was never designed
to be that way
this one was very scary this is a
website called beneath the table beneath
the tangles and they're talking about
eight anime recommendations for
Christian viewers interesting so they're
not necessarily a Christian site but
they're saying we want to give you some
things if you're a Christian here's our
top eight animes that we would recommend
to you so you would think okay well this
is going to be safe
this one is called Kino's Journey the
beautiful world when I looked at the
picture the first question that came to
my mind was
is that a boy or is that a girl because
I mean
it's carrying a gun on its side normally
that's that's a guy you don't normally
see girls you know I'm yeah I'm not
being a bigot but that's just that's
normally a man position
but then you look at the figure and it's
like it's sort of the legs look like
almost a feminine figure yeah more of a
feminine figure
so I kept reading and let me show you
actually I'm gonna go to this one first
um
this is a picture out of one of the
stories of this same anime
now that looks like a girl that is a
girl what is she doing pointing a gun at
you she's pointing a gun at whoever was
reading
okay so this is supposed to be
recommendation for Christians
and it's a little girl pointing
a gun a firearm
and then the Lord just reminded me in
Psalms 101 God said I will set no Wicked
thing before mine eyes yea I hate the
work of those that turn aside off the
path of righteousness
now let me show you if I can if I can
read this from here this is from another
website called anime corner and this is
the title of the of the article five
lgbtq plus anime perfect for pride month
and they're talking about Kino's Journey
this website says this is perfect for
Christians this is in the top eight for
Christians this website says this is one
of the Prime ones for lgbtq plus pride
month yeah it can't be both yeah I mean
like really
in there they go in and they talk about
the fact that Kino
which is the main character
the whole story is about Keno traveling
on a talking motorcycle so this
character uses a motorcycle that can
talk the name of the motorcycle is
Hermes
Hermes is a pagan God okay why would I
recommend this to a Christian
and then you go a little bit farther and
listen to what it says Kino's journey is
incredibly unique even among lgbtq plus
anime
strictly speaking Kino's gender is
ambiguous there is never an explicit
label put to the gender in particular
terms
Kino has an androgynous design and
generally responds to questions about
identity with I'm just Kino
in today's language most people seeking
to find a label would probably say that
Keno is non-binary and this seems like a
fitting description
but whether you believe Keno is not
non-binary or just ambiguous gender
identity and presentation is a
consistent backdrop of kano's Journey
the anime is fantastic and
thought-provoking Kino's character is
just one great part of the amazing
combination they do talk later on in the
story that Kino comes out as actually
being a girl
but
throughout it you have to dig to
actually find that out it shouldn't be
that way yeah it's like in the Bible God
said men are not supposed to wear
women's clothing and women are not
supposed to wear men's clothing I
shouldn't have to meet somebody and have
to dig to find out if that's a man or a
woman right it should be obvious
yeah so that was scary for me that you
know this is recommended for Christians
in Galatians 5 and I'm just going to
highlight this it talks about the works
of the flesh it says the works of the
flesh are these adultery fornication
uncleanness idolatry lasciviousness
which is the desire to look at flesh
witchcraft wrath Strife sedition heresy
Envy murder drunkenness reveling which
is like partying or a rave and then he
says of the which I tell you before as I
have also told you in time past those
that do such things as these shall not
inherit the kingdom of God so that's the
works of the flesh
and then the Apostle Paul goes on and
says but the fruit of the spirit Is This
Love that means sacrificing yourself on
behalf of others joy peace
long-suffering being patient with people
even when they're wrong gentleness
goodness Faith meekness meekness
humility
Temperance against such there is no law
for those that are Christ have crucified
the flesh with the affections and lusts
thereof so here we've got two kingdoms
the kingdom of the Flesh and the kingdom
of God's spirit
and they're quite in contrast to each
other I like how the bible really just
quickly goes over you know all these
things that that you know will be
damaging to your salvation but if you
have these fruits of the spirit you know
what I mean this is what you want and
and to see those next to each other is
is really I think a nice comparison and
going yeah do do when you watch anime
here's a great test
does that anime have those elements in
it amen or does it have the spirit of
God does it have joy peace
long-suffering patience goodness
faithfulness right I mean if you if you
can answer yes to that and you can do
that with anything the music we're
listening to the movies we're watching
the books we're reading it's that simple
it's not complicated if you need to know
where it came from all you got to do is
look at those those two lists Jesus said
in Matthew 7
by their fruits you shall know them and
this was funny because you it's like you
had read the slide I think before
resentment unforgiveness bitterness
anger hatred violence murder selfishness
arrogance and pride spiritualism and
Witchcraft and last but not least moral
impurity sensuality and perversion so so
let's talk about the sensuality a little
bit I don't know if you're going to
unpack this or get into this okay yeah
because there is a lot of sensuality in
these kind of cartoons and and and once
again I want to make that super super
distinction these are cartoons we're
talking about you know I think in an
American-made cartoons Bugs Bunny these
kind of things there were elements of
this you know there was Disney's always
put out these sensuous characters that
were you know the the yeah they have
accentuated body parts and things like
that so we had our version of that too
but it was timid comparison to a whole
nother level and makes the American
cartoons just seem like you know Childs
I know baby toddler material compared to
do you know what's weird
we were founded as a Christian Nation
so our departure from righteousness has
been a slower departure Japan was not
originally a Christian Nation less than
one percent even profess faith in God
so all of these things that we look at
and go oh that's that's I can't watch
that they they're like well why I mean
who said that's bad there's no yeah
there's no no boundary there
now I'm just going to show some pictures
to illustrate this bitterness resentment
and unforgiveness is that Sailor Moon I
I have no idea I think it is Sailor Moon
this is one of the the animes that we
actually looked into in our documentary
and and there is so much sensuality
witchcraft they're all named after all
the different elements of the earth and
stuff but interesting you remember one
of the first slides we looked at the
show of their accountants Witnesses
against them here's the fruits of the
spirit here's the works of the flesh the
flesh is prompted by the devil or by
evil spirits so when you look at their
countenance you know who is influencing
them who is inspiring them so I looked
at that picture and I was just like that
doesn't look happy I wouldn't want my
children looking at that
here's another one anger hatred violence
murder and rage and you can look at the
eyes the eyes you know are like the
windows to the soul the Japanese uh uh I
don't know if it's just a cultural thing
but they just in these cartoons they
they often yell at each other it's like
sometimes when you watch you know scenes
from it or whatever like
you know it's like yeah maybe not a
cultural thing it's just like they're
very intense with their display of
emotion this one I don't remember the
character but
have you ever heard of somebody saying
well she's green with jealousy or Green
With Envy that's a common term
interesting
um and here you see these green eyes and
obviously that's not a happy face that's
not somebody that's got peace Joy
self-sacrifice humility
arrogance and pride and that's
throughout almost all of them not all of
them but almost that's just a common
theme you can look at his countenance
and that's it's arrogant everything
about it is just prideful and arrogant
this Pride was one of the main features
that I saw in Dragon Ball Z he was
constantly like you can try to kill me
but you'll never take my pride you know
and it's like yeah that was something
that he kept Goku kept hammering over
and over and over again and it was all
about his pride and do you know that's
so weird too because that's the one
thing that caused Satan to fall from
Heaven yep it's one one of the sins that
that God actually says is is one of the
hardest ones because you know it's like
if you're a very prideful person yeah
and I think this is this is interesting
in light of this conversation if you're
watching something where that character
has a lot of Pride the reason we like to
watch things I think there's a real deep
psychological connection to things that
we like to invest and watch and pay
attention to you're not watching movies
that you don't identify with yeah if you
have nothing in common with that
character or you don't wish you were in
that scene with that character you would
never watch it you you get attached to
these characters and then you
psychologically Place yourself as that
character that we everyone does that
that's why that's why they make the hero
that gets the girl that you wish you
were the hero that got the girl yeah and
all of a sudden it's like it's like what
is this doing to us if these characters
are chock full of pride
yeah and pride is the spirit Yeah by
beholding we become changed into that
element that's right that's scary I mean
that's scary
this is
the part that we really want to focus on
I had to be careful with what picture to
use because some of the pictures are
they're alluring they're they're
designed to Allure
um you can look at this and this is
obviously with anime
they make the characters by their face
look like they're 10 12 14 years old
but by their body they'll make them look
like they're 18 to 24.
and that doesn't happen in real life
right and one of the things that that
really bothered me was is the eyes like
not all but most of the eyes for female
anime characters are huge and I looked
up a lot of research to find out why and
what they told was partially true but it
was only a partial truth one of the
things that they said was the large eyes
helped to express emotion easier so
that's why they do that but what they
don't tell you is
the large eyes portray
a young age and they portray innocence I
think that's why we like when we see
pictures of like cats with big eyes you
know or drawings where dogs you know
like yeah you know when they made the um
cartoon character Shrek and there was
that little cat in there and he'd hold
his little hat up and he'd have these
big eyes you know and everybody goes oh
it's innocence yeah you look at it and
you go that's cute but yeah when they
have a female adult body with these cute
little eyes yeah it's it's it's opening
a door and it's promoting something
planting a seed into your mind that
should not be there that's right for
pedophilia or incest or something
um I'm going to show just a couple of
slides here
and this this connects to what we're
talking about with the sensuality a lot
of people that have been into anime
started off watching Pokemon
um there was a character in Pokemon
called Vulpix he was a little fox and
we've got the picture there and if you
look he's got one two three four five
six tails
this character in Japan is called a
kitsuni which is the word a Japanese
word for a fox
but it's also a special type of fox that
is said to possess
Supernatural ability and every hundred
years they say that this type of fox
will grow another tail so when you get
seven tails on there you've got one
that's got extreme Supernatural power
but you also notice that the mask of the
fox is used throughout Japan and that
really caught my attention
I do not remember the name of the show
but on the left we've got a picture
there of a young man and you can see
he's got that same mask
um and the girl has got her back to him
in the story for this anime this young
man is probably I'm guessing 14 to 16
years old maybe 17 years old he started
befriending this little girl when she
was like seven years old well like what
is a teenager doing hanging around with
a seven or eight year old little girl
grooming yeah that's exactly right so
but he would always wear this mask so
he's being a friend to her and she's a
little girl with big eyes and innocent
but this has come into the point where
he finally says I want to reveal who I
really am so he's pulling the mask back
and here's a couple of Japanese uh
depictions of the kasuni uh the fox you
can see over here on the right the fox
with you know all the multiple tales and
then the the fox down on the lower right
hand corner where he's taking the mask
off
and then you've got the fox up there and
you look at the Fox on the left it's got
a female's face as a mask there is a
common phrase that we use here in in
America and probably through a lot of
the English-speaking World they'll say
that someone is cunning like a fox or is
cunning as a fox or as shrewd as a fox
and I thought where did we get that from
well the the phrase cunning like a fox
known throughout the world within
Shamanism and many of the indigenous and
folk religions the foxes said to be a
symbol of cunning craftiness
slyness luck a trickster
clever to another one's harm
sensual deceitful Wily and mischievous
that's that's worldwide that sounds like
the devil well yeah do you know that
even the Native American Indians they
use their shamans use the Fox as a
symbol for all of those characteristics
and they used it to channel Spirits
back years ago this was two years before
I was born
1967 there was a rock and roll singer
who was a legend they they say he's in
the martial arts hall of fame or not
martial arts the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame
Jimi Hendrix released their first debut
album and on that album was a song
called foxy lady
the lyrics were not good
but I was like why would you call a
woman a fox and even today people will
say that oh she's a fox what where do we
get that idea what is beautiful about a
fox that you would equate that with a
woman and the Lord helped me to find the
common thread
this is an actual picture of a Japanese
lady holding one of the katsuni masks
so here you have a woman wearing a fox's
mask which is actually the exact
opposite of the truth the fox was
actually wearing a woman's mask
here's one of the anime pictures
it says the katsuni they were servants
or messengers of what was called the
Inari or the Shinto spirits
so these spirits in the Japanese
religion the Shinto religion they would
use the foxes as their Messengers to go
tell things go do things and
specifically it was the katsuni
here is a man wearing the katsuni mask
it is it's funny because he's doing the
the horns of Horus with his left hand
and that's also interesting he's using
his left hand to do that not the right
hand
that picture he doesn't look like a girl
but you can tell they've made him very
slender they've they've changed his
appearance and throughout all of anime I
noticed that there's often a question of
is that a boy or is that a girl it's
almost like you can't tell anymore if
you look at the image on the right hand
side this is an ancient Japanese picture
and there is a warrior a man and you see
there's a fox above his head and you see
the thing behind it I thought originally
that was like a cloth or something it's
not it's his Tails oh yeah it's his
Tails yes and there's snakes involved
there too right all wrapped around him
yeah but those are his tails and this
man is like he's looking like look at
his hand position he's like what just
happened and then look on the floor yeah
there's somebody he's like either
knocked out or that's a woman's body oh
interesting the fox
was using her face to seduce him and
when he got what he wanted then he turns
on the man and the man is like what just
happened
according to Japanese
um mythology this is what the consuming
what they say about the consuming and
the Shinto Kami spirits
they say the katsuni is said to possess
magical powers such as shape-shifting
that means it's a fox but it can make
itself appear as a woman or a man
shape-shifting illusion deception
they're known to be immoral and they're
also known for sensuality this is in the
Japanese religion
the commie spirits who use these things
these are their common characteristics
and things that they use mudras mantras
spells Chi or Key Energy
homosexuality bisexuality pedophilia and
transgenderism
that's all throughout anime I mean all
throughout it and now you start seeing
why people are calling a woman a fox
it's it's a woman that's cunning she's
deceptive she's mischievous she's a
temptress she's she's someone that will
flirt with you and maybe you can get
something from her tonight and then
she'll disappear tomorrow and she says
she's not going to tell anybody when you
and I went to
that uh that Christian Academy and these
were were girls at this girl's dorm
that were between the ages of 14 and 18
years old
and one of the things that the lady that
had invited invited us to come speak
there she said I want you to speak
specifically on anime I really want you
know a little light to do this and I
asked her I said you know why what you
know what's causing you to think there's
a problem with that she said the girls
are no longer motivated they don't want
to do anything they they seem like
they're lost like they have no purpose
in life they don't want to get a job
they don't want to progress they just
they just kind of are like you know numb
numb
and she said she was also they were
experiencing a lot of depression and
that was the first time that that had
ever I'd even thought about that but
something clicked because which we're
gonna sometime in the future we'll do a
show on on pornography and depression
and how the relation there but many
people that are involved in pornography
experience the same thing Suicidal
Thoughts depression apathy
um so all of a sudden you go okay
pornography sensuality immorality and
depression and then here you've got
Anime which is full of sensuality and
all that stuff and depression this is
such a common thing that
um you see a lot of YouTubers who are
you know promoting different animes they
always kind of say once you finish an
anime you've spent all this time
learning all these characters and and
getting to know them and then it's gone
and it's like like a friend is lost left
your life and it leaves you depressed
and they talk about how the the best fix
for it is to get involved in another
anime and you jump from anime to anime
and and there's there's tons of YouTube
videos on how to deal with your
post-anime depression and it's like wait
why are we discussing like like I know
how to just Band-Aid it rather than
going what's the cause of your
depression it's like hey if you're
having troubles with that cocaine I got
a better drug for you right maybe don't
do that yeah you know kind of a thing
the devil has got people
so common symptoms of what you just
described post-anime depression syndrome
sadness lack of motivation staring
blankly into space moping around like a
slug manner
depression-like symptoms the world seems
hopeless you don't know what to do with
your life anymore and you seriously
doubt you will ever find joy in the
world again this is from an anime
website oh yeah there's there's there's
actual clinical studies that I've I've
read that that they described this as
like you know a thing that happens yeah
and this is what's scary this is what
they say of how to fix it start a new
anime isn't that crazy is this crazy
write about the anime you just watched
read articles about the anime download
photos of the anime online play music or
a video game that is based on the anime
that you just watched that's causing you
to be so depressed right because like a
drug and and I think that's what we're
we're hitting on here I think that there
is real like endorphin or uh yeah
chemical releases and chemical releases
like when you see something that's like
racy you know I mean yes like sensuality
or killing or something like that right
you get a little bit of a rush from that
and and so this is a fix and they talk
about it like as if it's a drug as well
and so you know of course what does a
drug addict want to do to get rid of the
feelings that that he's left lower than
when he started is to do more of the
drugs to get more normally it's got to
be a stronger drug yep and that's what
happens that's why people start over
here with a seemingly benign or innocent
anime and within a short amount of time
I mean literally you you go talk to kids
I encourage any of you guys out there if
you know anyone that's involved in anime
ask them are you watching any anime
that's darker than what the anime that
you first watch and you will you will
hear this time and time and time again
yeah that's exactly what that happens
that's exactly right that's scary yeah
it's a drug it's like a drug that is
scary
the reality of pads and its spiritual
Roots anime and manga are based on a
culture and characters who do not
believe and have faith in the Lord Jesus
Christ therefore these films teach the
audience to look inward at self rather
than upward to the almighty God with
whom nothing shall be impossible
it is so true
now what this what the anime website
said is watch another anime You Know
download pictures about the anime second
Peter 2 verse 19 says while they
promised them Liberty and freedom they
themselves are slaves of corruption for
of whom a man is overcome of the same as
he brought into bondage
now this is a couple of just really good
things from God's word because I don't
want to leave on just the negative
that's right
listen to what the Lord says to each of
us and I this verse is like yeah it's in
my heart now because of of the bondage I
was in with other things
he says o Israel and put your name there
when you hear that o Israel
thou Hast destroyed thyself but in me is
thine help I will be your king for where
is any other that may save thee in all
of thy cities I will Ransom you from the
power of the Grave I will redeem you
from death o death I will be thy plagues
o grave I will be thy destruction and
repentance shall be hid from mine eyes
that means I won't change my mind amen
Jesus knows the circumstances of Every
Soul the greater the sinner's guilt the
more you need the savior
Jesus's heart of divine love and
sympathy is drawn out most of all for
the one who is the most hopelessly
entangled in the snares of the enemy
with his own blood he has signed the
emancipation papers of the race wow
that's powerful that is powerful
Jesus is the only hope of the Soul by
faith every soul may say with the
psalmist whom have I in heaven but thee
and there is none upon the Earth that I
desire beside thee now listen to this
statement the moment The Sinner lays
Hold On Christ by faith that moment your
sins are no longer upon you do you
remember John the Baptist said Behold
the Lamb of God who takes away the sin
of the world the moment you believe that
promise and you lay hold on Jesus that
moment your sins are no longer upon you
amen Christ stands in the sinner's place
and declares I have borne your guilt I
have been punished for your
transgressions I have taken your sins
and I have put my righteousness upon you
in Christ The Sinner stands Guiltless
before the law of God Amen it doesn't
mean simply forgiven it means you never
did it
Justified just as if I did not do that
amen amen
two more verses listen to this God says
and thine ears remember we talked about
these people hearing voices in their
head listen to what the Lord says thine
ears shall hear a word behind you saying
this is the way my son my daughter
walkie in it
for thus saith the Lord God behold I
even I will both search my sheep and
seek them out as a Shepherd seeketh out
his flock in the day that he is among
his sheep that are scattered
so will I seek out my sheep and I will
deliver them you out of all places where
you have been scattered in the dark and
cloudy day amen amen what a beautiful
promise God is I mean that's a promise
it is a problem so that means when the
devil's telling you you've gone too far
you've done too much you've done it too
many times you open up that verse in
Ezekiel 34 verse 11 and 12 and read that
out loud and read your name into it read
it out loud and every time you read that
God's spirit is going into you and your
faith will grow amen amen and I love it
that the Bible describes or at least God
when he's speaking through Isaiah he's
saying I will find my sheep right the
the idea that Jesus Is Our Shepherd
right and and sheep are very interesting
they will actually listen to the voice
of the shepherd and if they know the
voice of the shepherd they will not go
to someone else amen follow that and so
you have these two distinct voices in
your life one of them is the voice of
the enemy one of them is feeding your
mind with Unholy things thoughts
emotions whatever that that that you
know is corrupting you and one of them
is saying I will take away those sins
and give you a new heart I'll take that
Stony heart out of your chest and I'll
give you a new heart amen and so I think
it is so amazing we want to listen to
the voice of the shepherd you want to
get familiar with the voice of the
shepherd don't listen to the voice of
the enemy all he's going to do is make
you depressed saddened anxious angry
guilty guilty and and so much so that
even even suicide and things like that
are are are things that a lot of people
that get really deep into this whole
anime world are beginning to to
experience and feel thoughts of and
depression that just seems like there's
no end to it and so I really believe
that if we stand on what the Bible is
literally promising to do that is to
take this stuff away from us and give us
joy give us peace give us long suffering
all those elements Eric is that what you
want in your life amen do you really
want joy
do you know it's funny because when I
was not living for God and I was in the
martial arts and I was into the movies
in Hollywood and rock and roll I didn't
have joy when I went to sleep at night
time I never went to to sleep with joy I
went to sleep with an emptiness and a
hollowness and fear because I used to
think what if Jesus comes back and I'm
in this condition that's right I'm not
ready to meet him I don't I'm scared you
know and now there's none of that yeah
yeah well we hope you guys were blessed
by today's discussion and uh remember
Jesus is the one that saves us uh you
know if you like these shirts amen check
out lightwear dot shop it's an awesome
Ministry that has a lot of amazing
graphics and you know we really designed
those things to to be able to wear your
witness out into the world and uh I I
believe that the word of God has a
transforming power amen and uh Eric
thank you so much for blessing thanks
for having me it's been great being here
again we think that thank you guys for
joining up with us and don't forget to
like subscribe check out our video on
anime we'll put the link in the
description below but seriously if you
have more questions about this please
write it in the comments below we will
we will try to respond to all the
questions that seriously come if um if
there's something you need to really
private message us then then
um you know we can we can begin to have
that dialogue but we're making this
content so that it'll hopefully make you
more aware but at the end of the day
Jesus is the one that we need to spend
our time with and so we hope that you
guys are inspired by today's topic and
thank you for watching thank you patreon
supporters for supporting you guys are
literally helping us keep these lights
on and doing what we're doing so we just
love you and thank you and even if you
disagree with us we love you guys for
coming and watch watching this video all
the way to the end we'll see you guys on
the next weeks God bless you
[Music]
thank you